I think a lot of people are afraid of
death there's always still that
underlying fear that everyone has is to
you know is there gonna is it going to
be painful or you know scary or how am I
gonna die it's the mystery of the
unknown that scares people I think to
understand how many Americans deal with
their dead there may be no better place
to visit than the oldest embalming
school in the u.s. the Cincinnati
College of mortuary science or CCMS
since 1882 generation after generation
of morticians and training have come to
CCMS to become experts in the american
rituals of death and burial my friends
and i told him that i was going into the
funeral business they all just kind of
give me the same look like you want to
work with dead people erricka Kaiser's
uncle owns a funeral home where she
worked during college there were so many
ghost stories and misconceptions about
the the field that and people are just
too afraid to find out what it's all
about all cultures have ways of handling
dead bodies but most american christians
don't realize that how they treat their
dead makes them different from nearly
every other culture in the world america
is one of the few places where corpses
are routinely embalmed american funeral
directors know that their clients want
the dead to look as they did in life i
think in the eyes of a family they want
to see their loved one in a very natural
peaceful state in the US the goal of
embalmers is not just a disguise
it's power but to stop its inevitable
destruction in its tracks
this body donated to the school is
already decomposing but Erica and her
classmates will stop the decay for as
long as a few years by injecting the
corpse with several gallons of a
chemical preservative based on
formaldehyde this American practice of
lutein Lee embalming the dead would be
taboo in many other cultures even in
mortuary school embalming is practically
a ritual with clearly defined steps
first the body is cleaned and prepped
mouth closure it's crucial to get that
very natural next the embalmers locate
the blood vessel into which they will
pump the formaldehyde solution and you
have to work your way through that and
go ahead and cut the artery as the
embalming fluid enters the body it
displaces the blood which escapes
through an incision usually in the
jugular vein almost immediately the
corpse begins to harden this may seem
like a process dreamed up by a mad
scientist but in reality embalming has
deep historical and religious roots in
America embalming arose not from a quest
for immortality but from perhaps the
nation's greatest tragedy the Civil War
modern embalming techniques had just
been invented when hundreds of thousands
of young men began dying on battlefields
far from home for the first time
soldiers families could request that the
bodies of their sons and husbands be
preserved and returned for burial there
were many who welcomed the new technique
as a godsend
many Christians saw embalming as a
perfect fit with their religious beliefs
in which the body and the spirit would
be reunited at the resurrection as
diverse as the rituals we practice to
honor the dead to heal our grief we
united in our need to mark this most
final of all life
passages and to attempt to make sense of
what must remain a mystery